brett
at evergreen you had the security of
being sure there was no actual evidence
of your racism
what if there is racism in your past to
be found
uh a 26 year old who was a troubled 16
year old would appreciate your advice
such an amazing question yeah that's a
great question
um you know it's awkward now
because if you come clean
about this in some way then
there's always the question of whether
you're doing it cynically
but on the other hand everybody
understands
that youth involves stupidity
of many different kinds everybody used
to understand that everybody used to
understand it you're now being
persecuted for uh failures that frankly
everybody has
in their past and so um
i don't there's not a great answer to
the question i think in some sense
you're depending on people
recognizing that they don't want to be
judged based on what they were doing at
16 either
and to the extent that you are upfront
about i'm not comfortable looking at
myself at 16
i'm not comfortable with what i see and
here's you know in your case the
you know the uh the racial stuff that i
no longer um feel or believe and maybe i
didn't believe it then maybe i was
motivated to say it
for other reasons you thought you were
going to be cool or something like that
but you know look um
forgiveness and tolerance these are
essential
values and i will say we had a
very good friend in grad school you know
one of the people we were closest with
who had experimented in high school
with some of this you know white
supremacist stuff
i'm not sure i know this you do you've
just forgotten it because it's so out of
character with the wonderful person
that we spent all the time with oh okay
so
anyway the point was it was some kid
yeah doing stupid stuff and you know we
never
once thought about holding this against
this person because
it just obviously was not consistent
with their values
and you know we have to have the ability
to
to let people grow up you know i mean
this is i mean and we've written this
uh in the childhood chapter of our book
this is this is part of
this this is not something i've heard
elsewhere but this is part of the reason
that the screens and the social media
are so dangerous
is that it more in it memorializes
forever
all of the mistakes of youth and youth
and development are exactly the time
when you're supposed to be exploring
and if you don't make any mistakes then
you're not going to become a very
interesting
or or competent adult so you know
obviously
actually playing around with racist
ideas is um
is a is a greater kind of error than
a lot of people engage with but everyone
makes some kinds of errors and some
people make much graver errors than that
depending on what exactly your
your personal history of racism might
have looked like
and used to be that not just you know
not just the courts
but society could recognize uh that
forgiveness was actually the way
to a a more robust uh populace
rather than holding people accountable
for every single thing that they've ever
done
um but something about this you know
this goes back to our being so
visually dominant as primates that once
you've seen it once you've seen it
either in video or even in text it's
very very hard to forget
and the fact that social media just is
persistent
that we're being shown evidence of
everything from you know police
brutality
to some kids you know
exploration that wasn't socially okay
but it was a kid's exploration from a
long time ago
uh is causing people to glitch out and
forget that actually
we're supposed to be able to try to
understand and forgive
and heal and we're moving away from all
of those things
yeah um i guess i would say three final
things
one check out helen pluck rose's
tweet thread from last week in which she
describes
her own path to becoming the
highly insightful courageous
adult that she is anyway it's
absolutely extraordinary uh second thing
i would say is check out
majid noise friend of ours and his
path from being a uh a muslim
he's an islamic extremist he was an
islamic extremist
and he realized the error of his ways
and
he is spending his uh adult years
um trying to make the world a better
place including a recent
very successful hunger strike in defense
of the uyghur
in china which forced the british
parliament to debate the matter i don't
know
how it's come out but anyway it's quite
an extraordinary thing
and i would also say there's a lot to be
said
for um
finding people that you
had these prejudices against and
um who are uh
willing to see you for who you are and
you know correcting any residual
prejudice and
being candid about where you were i
think you might find it
[Music]
cathartic